- And Robert, you just turned 18.
So you're officially a grown man.
How did you celebrate?
- I know.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah, it's a, a huge milestone.
It feels very surreal.
It was a, a really wonderful
little celebration at the zoo,
just with, with friends
and family here at home.
But it is definitely really exciting.
You know, wildlife conservation
is, is everything to us.
Protecting our, our worldwide wildlife.
- Yes
- And now turning 18,
I get to be more stuck-in
with all of the different
conservation work that we do
around the world.
So it really is a big honor for
me to get to work full-time,
and to this wonderful new chapter of life.
It's really, really exciting.
I'm very, very proud definitely.
- Congratulations, congratulations.
Terri, this new season covers a lot.
What can people expect?
- Well, we are just going hammer and tong
over here at Australia Zoo.
We've got a beautiful wildlife hospital
where we've treated over 110,000 animals.
So it's a lot of action with echidnas.
I don't know what the deal was,
but we just kept getting
little orphaned echidnas in.
And we raised them up and
released them back to the wild,
but it's all the dramas of raising babies.
And when the echidnas are tiny,
when they first hatch out of the egg,
they look kind of like jelly bean blobs.
- They're hilarious.
- They're really funny.
They don't have any spikes,
and they're really weird,
and that's kind of fun to see.
And then of course, it's
keeping our animals happy.
So it's making sure they
have beautiful homes,
and wonderful environments to live in.
And it's all the dramas
of reconstructing beautiful habitat areas,
and, you were moving alligators.
- A lot of animal rescues as well.
A lot of what we do is going out,
and rescuing animals that
are, that are in need.
So, there's some really exciting,
scary, heart pounding moments.
And some special family times as well.
It's a very personal look into
how we continue this
incredible wildlife legacy.
- Yeah, I think Grace
is the star of the show.
- [Robert & Bindi] She is.
- I'm sure.
She stole it with those
cheeks, I'll tell you that.
And when I come to Australia, I'm coming,
I'm coming to visit you guys.
- Yes!
- Yes, definitely.
- Definitely, please do.
- You're a wildlife warrior.
- Always welcome.
- Yes!
Take care.
And I'm coming for Grace,
because I want to see those cheeks!
(Taraji laughs)
- Yes!
- Take care, stay safe.